predictions for 2017 you've already
touched on a bunch of these between new
games coming out this year and that
delays cancellations Hardware can switch
in the Scorpio potentially a new
Nintendo classic console re-release we
want to get into what we think is going
to happen this year we have another
companion article publishing today later
today basically different editors takes
on what they think will happen this year
but I want to get your guys thoughts on
what we can foresee in the future in
2017 I'll start though I think in terms
of software you see halo 6 they're gonna
notice that microsoft needs to I think
Eddie Makua our news editor study
predicts that there will be split screen
this time around halo 5 Guardians did
not have it much to the ire of longtime
Halo fans like myself who you know love
playing for player splitscreen of those
games eddie makuch they'll have it this
time do you think it'll come out and
fall too yeah I think it'll release in
October october twenty third and then
destiny too i think will be shown this
year but i don't think we're not gonna
see it might be a teaser might be a
trailer probably three i wouldn't be
surprised see destiny to you guys agree
yeah yeah it's about time yeah i think
so i think Destiny the destiny trains
finally whatever steam ahead to begin
with it's finally just running out of it
the expansions taking King you know rise
of iron I was not impressed with taking
revamp the game enough and added some
interesting end game elements but I
don't know between those in the dark
below I was not over all that impressed
with the the long run of this game the
more I played it but there are a lot of
fans of it and I know people still play
it Eric Tay still plays everyone smile
don't know if he has recently but I
think destiny to would be the shot in
the arm the bungee needs right now and a
lot of Destiny fans need ya to say the
least and bring it to PC yeah do it that
would be pretty sweet I MapReduce food I
like do you like destiny do you care too
much for destiny I want to like destiny
I really like Phantasy Star Online back
in the day and destiny always kind of
reminded me of that a little bit yeah
obviously its first person but um yeah I
just add I couldn't get into it yeah if
you're watching our live show we just
said a few of us think Mass Effect
Andromeda might get delayed again Jake
that's one of your predictions though
for those just joining us on YouTube why
do you think mass effect
was gonna get the legs because
everything we've talked about in about a
year of people leaving the studio coming
back to it leaving uh did I put that
down yeah I did put that down on the
dock that I think masking it too late
yeah okay yes Eddie did well yeah I know
I just said it but like for the running
order I think I wouldn't be crazy
surprised if it did March 21st is close
though it's two months away let's hope
they don't pull the last minute pull the
rug out on her feet here's the other
thing we're anything and believe I heard
someone talking about this on a podcast
so but could you pre-ordered the game
beforehand I feel like pre-orders for
that just open like right now mess from
ass Andromeda yeah another they've
finally announced a release date oh i
don't know like probably did they should
probably have opened up released the
date a lot longer than three months
before the game came out yeah i mean
that was cuz i think it was like an a
bioware blog thing Aaron Flynn tweeted
it saying hey here's a release day for
you wondering uh oh by the way I guess
you can pre-order it now you can so
super deluxe edition deluxe edition does
it come with the the Mako thing think so
yeah man so mass effect 3 Mass Effect
Andromeda mass effect 3 I like mass
effect 3 a lot whatever people say Mass
Effect Andromeda kind of has an
uncertain future now let's let's hope
it's fantastic will be hopeful for that
um anyway Pete what about a super
nintendo classic yes it would make sense
they should do it they react like the
patent for the controller or something
yes that's the deal some people are
speculating that might have something to
do with the super nintendo other people
are speculating in smaller circles that
there's a company called 8-bit do or a
bit though they do a lot of really great
retro themes or related products one of
them being a wireless Bluetooth
controller that looks exactly the Super
Nintendo controller and is actually
really good but anyway I think it's more
likely we're going to see the Super
Nintendo classic the NES classic yeah I
like the end well the NES classic he
just had that like trouble with having
enough units for everybody yeah they
still have that trouble I still do they
still did on going yeah I couldn't
probably couldn't get one if I want to
who do you think you are and the home
I'm not if you're Brown NES expert you
just have him stashed away in your house
and who sells I think he is I don't
think that's me uh I'm gonna hoard snea
Super Nintendo classics and I'm gonna
I'm
gonna not let you have a see long-term
investment money one of them yeah I may
be awesome I would love to play Super
Metroid Zombies Ate My Neighbors I would
love to play all those games again what
I would prefer and I'll make this my
prediction is that in 10s is that
Nintendo actually takes the Virtual
Console seriously again and is able to
unify their accounts online so people
don't have to buy games like the ones
you just mentioned a third time if they
pick up a switch they can just use their
account and download it and play it that
would be read so I don't even think they
need a super nintendo classic but again
there's people going by the switch right
so or they won't buy the wii u so they
can use Virtual Console one's perfect
for them do you see much happening with
virtual reality this year in terms of do
you think it'll keep going with its
momentum I mean sales weren't great last
year but I think last year you know more
and more titles came out that showed
developers are taking it seriously and
maybe we should too developers are
taking it seriously and I think
consumers are to a degree but I think
it's more out of curiosity and the fact
that it's affordable and it does
something worth being excited about but
in terms of it really taking off maybe
I'm just not doing my job but I can't
think of a single VR game on the horizon
that I'm that I'm excited about res evil
7 is the first one that comes in mind
but that's like a couple weeks away but
you can also play it and I'm not excited
about that like that's that's cool for
people who own a PlayStation VR and I'm
excited about the game itself but the VR
portion of that is not like a good sign
that OVR is here and doing something
special it's VR is a means to experience
you know traditional media okay fine
we've done that move beyond that show us
what virtual reality really can do and I
think that there's a lot of places that
are still spinning their wheels trying
to you know rev that stuff up and get it
ready or even just experimenting with
what works and what doesn't sure so well
I think we'll see a lot of hardware
incremental improvements I think we'll
see some costs go down it's already gone
down on the pc front like you can get
much more affordable hardware to play VR
games on including PlayStation so I
think we'll see more of that before we
see more you know big games that really
do say vr is amazing it's here this is
why yeah in terms of other predictions
any others i'm i think crackdown 3 will
release with or around the scorpio
sounds about right so that would have to
announce that like any day now I feel
like Scorpio is what closest
did they even say no they say like 2017
yeah you're at something so so that I'll
be could befall yeah first of all I
don't video I would definitely say it's
gonna I would hope crackdown 3 is
definitely a really stay for that know
any other predictions crystal ball I
have 117 yeah I think we're gonna see
cyberpunk 2077 for the first time uh was
that trailer think 2013 Witcher 3 fan
and at the end of the trail they said
it's ready when it's ready or it'll be
ready when it's ready and I think
they're just about ready to start
showing things off yeah do I don't think
we'll see a lot I don't think I'll see
gameplay maybe we'll see gameplay but I
think we'll definitely get another
trailer e3 or something like that CD
Projekt RED do you think they'll just
keep going like a massive open world
like the witcher 3 with this cuz I don't
know much about the cyberpunk property I
mean I know generally like what they're
going I mean I we don't really know
anything like we've heard like like they
hired like vehicle like people to work
on like via guy don't know that's called
vehicle developers now but we hired a
guy who commissioned are um guy comes in
with a wrench so I mean it sounds like
it's gonna be another big open world RPG
but I'm feeling it'll be more like third
person like a like shooter combat rather
but we don't know anything about that
and I think I think they're gonna be
shown something off they were working on
it when I was there yeah um didn't try a
big and I just like not worse all right
yeah I just like walk through the
offices know like here everyone's hard
at work on cyberpunk don't ask about
cyberpunk just about Gwen yeah yeah it's
good it's not cyberpunk though um yeah
yeah now now is the time and also you're
gonna get a hot thumbnail for this
breakout too cuz not don't use that
thumbnail but well hell you know that
all the expansions are out for Witcher 3
now and like with um yeah I mean they're
one line is they are done with it would
like because they were like the people
were asking if they were gonna like
upgrade the witcher 3 4 playstation 4
pro and they said no we're not working
on the witcher 3 anymore because we want
to focus all on cyberpunk yeah and Gwen
I mean Gwen is a very small team I think
they said there was like 12 people or
something like that and they've been
beefing up their team quite a bit so
this and it's gotta be soon cyberpunk
will be the first game that's not a
witch
game from there for them yeah yeah yeah
so I have all the faith in the world and
CD Projekt RED especially if they're
kind of sticking to that you know like
you just said open-world structure that
they did so well with these uh you know
emergent storylines and kind of player
different choice that the witcher 3 was
great for so yeah here's hoping the
cyberpunk 27 does happen any other
predictions I think if it comes out this
year within the year still after the
fact Metal Gear survive will be a free
game on PlayStation Plus is it not all
ready for you did you pay for it was I
completely forgot about that game until
right now thanks Peter you guys are all
going there you go so if you forgot
about Metal Gear survive there's your
there's your reminder to follow a pure
brown on twitter if you want a daily
reminder he's gonna keep telling
everybody about metal your survive from
knowing but yeah anyway let us know what
you think about 2017 what you think's
gonna happen any games you think you're
gonna get delayed cancelled moved around
shuffled into the mix shuffle back out
of the mix let us know your thoughts in
the comments below
[Music]
you